So to see what the programmer
has to go through,
let's look at the message
passing program.
This is a relatively simple program.
What it's trying to do is compute a sum
of a relatively large array
in parallel on four cores.
So this is the overall array size.
It has 1024 elements.
This is the number of
processors we have.
In a message passing program,
each of the processors will
get one quarter of the array.
They can not access each
other's memory directly, so
each one of them only allocates its
part of the array in its memory.
Each of them will have
its own sum variable, and
then what happens is each of them
iterates over its part of the array,
adding those array elements to the sum.
This of course assumes that
the elements of the large array have
somehow been distributed
to all of the processors.
If they haven't been distributed
already, then we need to also write
code that will actually send
the elements of the array so
that each of them gets
a quarter of the array.
Once we have computed the sum,
we need to compute the final sum, and
to do that we have to communicate.
So what we will do is we will
have one of the processors act as
the summing up agent, and it will,
for every other processor,
receive the sum sent by that processor,
and
add it to its sum, and
then print the final overall sum.
What do the rest of the processors do?
Well what they do is they send to
processor 0 what they have collected so
far, and that's all they do.
So as you can see, we need to
explicitly send and then receive
things in order for communication
between processes to happen.
And also we have to explicitly control
what gets into whose part of memory.
We need to explicitly also,
in the program, figure out how to
match the sends and receives, because,
if we send something, and it's not
received, it's going to be a problem.
And also, if we wait to receive
something, and there is no send for
it, it's going to be a problem,
we get stuck here.
So we need to know how many
processes to wait for.
We need to send exactly what's
expected at the time, and so on.
But once we do all of this correctly,
it's very easy for the programmer to see
which parts of this program are going to
be expensive as far as communication is
concerned, because these are all local
accesses, so they are relatively fast,
and these are the only places
where we actually communicate.